what did you think uh when you saw the
versus thing
did you like like what are your thoughts
on it
played itself you think so played itself
every step of the way like for what you
sell no records like that don't nobody
even know you had album come out and you
did all this just to
[ __ ] on to people i was sliding with you
like
you know mack town [ __ ] basically yeah
i mean look look i
mean the guy that died you know what i'm
saying and then gucci showed his ass
so yeah i think i think when gucci
started getting disrespectful
man gucci been disrespectful no no but
i'm saying like i know
gucci was going to be disrespectful yes
he came out swinging with a whole
original new song no that wasn't new
i thought that first song was a new song
that song was this is gucci mane verse
geez that [ __ ] was out when
state strap came out we was watching
these views we was watching
this feud from out here i didn't know
them when this happened
and then i kind of fell over there like
and it was already going on
really gucci was in jail when i got
signed over there so
so let me ask you this because i think
like the other side of the coin is like
well
jeezy's showing people that
you know you can grow [ __ ] all that you
ain't no growing because
the homie rest in peace can't grow you
feel me right
you doing all this for what now you
didn't sh you didn't try to [ __ ] on this
[ __ ] your whole career and his whole
career
what's the use of y'all patching up like
i feel you
you know that's cool but like come on
man you didn't don't [ __ ] on this but
let me ask you this don't you think if
you're in jeezy's um
all that [ __ ] was for look no no i feel
you didn't work he thought it was gonna
work because originally it was supposed
to be jeezy versus ti yeah but
he man of course you got this that's why
we're talking about it now he did that
be
i don't know what makes him i think you
think of like where jeezy probably is in
life he's got kids in college he just
got married he's
definitely all the way out of that side
of the you know so we don't even know if
who he is then because this whole time
we've been knowing this person
you feel me yeah i think when someone
loses their life because of a situation
is when
you didn't even it couldn't even i'm not
saying you had to go do nothing but you
didn't have to do this
right like it's all raguchi already on
top he's the guy so let me ask you this
though tell me do you think
that alone if somebody sees what
happened with gizzy and gucci and they
in their personal situations with
somebody in this because i think that
that's
uh something that's so hard about
stopping some of this violence right
because
how are you going to tell me to not do
this to somebody when my cousin's dead
over this [ __ ] or you know my
partner or whoever and it's been so long
like you just brought
more [ __ ] out of the closet that was
already kind of like
you know it was calm down but do you
think yeah i mean i i mean
do you but do you think that there's
some good that could have came out of
that whether it was maybe influencing
somebody who watched the verses
i mean i feel like it was some good that
they did the song at the end and you
know it's cool
ain't nobody get shot or fight or
nothing like that you kind of showed a
little
but deep down the only reason we know
these people is because of these
situations and the people that you
claim to be right that you've been
telling us that you are and
who we fell in love with and at the end
of the day it's like
i don't think jeezy's been that guy for
a long time though as far as just like
the
persona he even the persona he gives out
to everyone yeah but
but we give it the benefit of the doubt
to be like you steal the guy
from thug motivation and all these other
inspiration
and you know you still somewhat of that
guy right right now when you go against
everything that you've
told us who you are it's like now we
lost all
faith in you you know what i mean street
wise and this is who you built your [ __ ]
on this is
why jesus jesus because of who you are
and what you've been doing
you know what i mean so i don't know i
don't know
you know what i mean but i know the
people i'll be around and the type of
people i'll be with
they just are feeling that [ __ ] yeah
just on the street side i feel like yeah
like that's what i don't even have to do
that you know i think i just think that
both there's like the street side of the
coin where it's like yeah like come on
someone died you don't ever do that
and then there's like a look well
obviously jeezy hasn't been
that guy for so long but it don't even
mean if you're that guy now you didn't
brought all these extra feelings up that
was already
like that man that's rest in peace he
got a kid he's got it he got a son
you know i mean he got family and all
that gucci over here talking about
smoking on that pack and
come on that gucci is the biggest [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying all you did was
you you put gucci like this yeah
you shoulda you man you you should've
just retired bro when you said you was
gonna retire three four years ago
like we don't we don't need all this
extra [ __ ] you think you're trying to do
go get married go
with your girl and all that y'all go do
what y'all doing get out the way
basically you're in the way bro get out
the way you know what i'm saying that's
fair
uh yeah yeah yeah i i thought from just
from a fans perspective i was man i was
watching that [ __ ] in the dark
like what the [ __ ] bro you let that ride
you down
and you come out with the bmf shirt on
and all that like man
[ __ ] don't even like you bro like what
you trying to do you feel me
i don't understand this uw he was
reaching
you know what i'm saying so yeah
whatever